hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 19 of my road to one bill series
I apologize for how long this episode
took to get out uh in between the
episodes I did start streaming uh so it
took me a little while to get in the
hang of actually streaming my progress
and recording at the same time uh so you
might notice this episode is a little
disjointed uh possibly a couple missing
Clips uh but that should hopefully be
fixed for the next episode uh so we're
going to start off by uh doing a bit of
uh black spinning now we have 80 magic
banked we bought enough to get 80 magic
and roughly uh 72 or 73 crafting after
that we're going to go ahead and finish
underground pass at some point and uh
train our melees up we need our defense
up as well a couple other melee stats
need leveling up before we can start
doing zoraa but we're getting pretty
close hopefully we can start doing them
and uh the next month or two all right
to break up our training we actually
have another 8K feathers coming in
thanks to uh tattle t
for 8K more feathers that's bring our
total up to close to 800k now all right
we're just doing some uh flax spinning
and our crafting levels are coming very
quickly there's another one that's 65
crafting uh we're hoping to get 75
eventually for the Slayer Rings uh but
uh it's not our priority mainly we're
looking for the magic experience all
right guys we deci had to take a quick
break from training our magic to come
get our Dragon Defender now we're on the
adamant one right now so hopefully it
won't take too long all right run to the
Rune Defender uh we also got 66 strength
I apologize for how quickly the clips
are kind of going through unfortunately
I didn't really get a chance to record
all the defender drops we had about
three left to go and uh it didn't take
us took us about 3 hours at the last
three Defender so it's not too bad all
right guys there is the dragon Defender
again I apologize for not catching all
the drops it was kind of hard a little
hectic when I was recording I appreciate
everyone who came out to the stream
that's all the people following me and
as a reward we are going to be dropping
with a mill worth of items these are all
the people who decided to show up to the
live stream and everyone pitched in and
we did a little bit of a drop event so I
know this isn't really a road to un
build progress uh clip but it was a lot
of fun and I did appreciate everyone who
decided to show up uh the stream was
really successful I got about 60 or 70
people watching and uh yeah so we
decided to do a little drop party after
and people pitched in everything that
they wanted to be dropped and we had a
lot of fun all right everything's on the
ground that guy's under the guilted
blade skirt lucky for him
um a lot of Rune items since we're in
the freeo play world uh we had to drop
Rune items for the most part uh but yeah
maybe next time we'll do a pay toplay
World drop but I had a lot of fun doing
it in free to play as well all right so
next up is going to be some Slayer uh
the reasoning behind this is we need to
get our defense level up for zra and uh
I like doing Slayer more than just
randomly training on rock crabs or sand
crabs or something like that M do have
done quite a bit of that as well on top
of that there's 57 Slayer so not too bad
all right so we're just about to finish
up our task of black demons this task is
pretty good mind you it's pretty
expensive we're burning through prayer
potions uh cuz we don't have any of the
initiate set or any other really pray
bonus
equipment and uh we're using cannonballs
as well but a pretty good task for
experience so it could be worse all
right so you may have noticed that we
actually upgraded our gear a little bit
too uh we have a black mask and on top
of that we have the dragon boots and the
dragon plate body think we're going to
to go ahead and get a dragon uh chain
skirt pretty soon or plate skirt
whatever it's called Uh I know a lot of
people think it looks newbie but I don't
really care it's going to give a little
bit of a better defense bonus and then
we can eventually get the fighter too
but I really don't want to do that right
now all right our next task going to be
157 greater demons that is really good
actually we can go to ne's Cave rail it
off quickly I think that's better combat
experience per hour and probably
actually Slayer experience for me and
it's not going to cost nearly as much
all right so we're just taking a moment
to just buy buy up some of these St
Mason shop items uh we're just going to
get the gold leaves for now but it's
just such Easy Money Can't recommend it
enough I just do this all the time now
always about a 4K margin on the leaves
all right so we went ahead and bought
the dragon chain body yeah look at that
doesn't that look sweet way better than
that stupid room plate body it's been a
while since we upgraded our armor so
it's kind of nice to get a bit of a
change coming in all right and now we're
back to the Slayer grind we're on our
greater demon task I like this one way
better pretty much better experience and
um Slayer experience and combat
experience and it's way quicker we're
getting pretty close to getting all our
Slayer points as well we only need about
six or seven more tasks maybe uh on top
of that we just hit 67 attack which is
pretty nice only three more levels all
right croakus coming in with 33k more
blue feathers that is a good amount man
they're becoming harder and harder to
come by too so congrats all right we're
just finishing up our greater demon task
that is going to be another task
complete uh 37 tasks in a row getting up
there all right let's grab our next task
and it's going to be black demons again
[__] I don't really want to do
that right now so I think we're going to
go off and do underground path all right
guys so we're starting off a quest that
I've been dreading to do for months now
and that is underground path now we have
the uh Clan chat with us and the live
stream so hopefully this won't be too
bad and uh we won't uh die at all all
right first obstacle let's see if we
make it over successfully made it over
not actually sure if we can fail that
one but uh yeah still off to a good
start all right so that tile M section
was not too bad at all uh we only
probably fell like three or four times
and uh we are kind of running out of
food though so that might be a problem I
have no clue how this plank is not
triggering the Trap underneath me but
I'm not complaining too much we're just
Gathering the orbs of light all right
just dig under this suspicious looking
uh piece of dirt here and yeah I guess
we're off that was not hard either all
right we got a little balance section
coming in here a lot of deadly spikes
below
us but uh ah [__] there's our first B um
but yeah we're pretty much all the way
through anyway so this isn't a big deal
oh what we [__] destroyed that
unicorn no I didn't want to do that I
thought I was just going to open the
gate a bloody forgot how dark this Quest
was all right now we're just going to
head down the well H we're just going to
use the crushed crushed ass unicorn horn
on it and Oh wait we're not going down
the well we're going through the door I
guess all right there we go guys we've
made it to the shittiest part of the
quest the biggest chamber in the world
the underground path so now we're going
ahead and jumping through all these uh
little pitfalls here mind you we haven't
fallen yet we're off to the Witch's
House all right so we're at The Witch's
House now we have gotten our cat already
uh so hopefully we can just run inside
now and of course you can safe spot
everything I have yet to fall in the pit
though have not done it once yet so off
to a pretty good Quest so far we're
actually getting pretty close to being
over halfway I believe all right now we
got the ashes got this demonic summoning
going on right now just going to rub
that into our doll only two more of uh
iins Essence we need to get all right of
course you can safe spot the spider why
wouldn't you be able to do that H this
part's not too hard either magic short
bow coming in pretty huge all right guys
we are at Ian's fight we got the last uh
piece of his soul now we're just trying
to run through here we have to make sure
we don't die or else have to go through
this whole thing again a it's
teleporting me come on let's do it let's
do it and all right that's it guys Quest
completed that really was not too bad
only took me about an hour and a half
and I had no idea what I was doing so I
think I got lucky I did not fall down
the pit once not once I was even trying
to because I was quicker to actually
fall down for a section of the quest all
right we're about to get the reward here
there we go underground pass complete
five Quest points 3K agility experience
3K attack experience and Ian's blast not
sure how useful that's going to be now
uh but mainly we got underground pass
complete so now we can go ahead do
regicide and then we'll be all ready to
do some zoraa all right guys that's
going to be uh pretty much the end of
the episode for today I understand it
was a little disjointed so I do
apologize for that and there were a
couple clips that I meant to record but
somehow it didn't get recorded that
being said let's have a look at our
stats all right so we're up to 67 attack
hopefully getting 70 attack next episode
um 66 of strength uh which we only got
one strength level but that's okay and
we got up to 60 defense on top of that
our magic levels now 77 and our crafting
level
65 uh and yeah let's have a look at our
gear now we have the dragon chain body
Dragon play legs and the dragon boots
next upgrade is definitely going to be
the um dragon sarget in exchange for a
whip and be honest you should buy an
amul of Fury and a Berserker ring not
too much more money to afford that we
have about 18 mil so far in the bank uh
we have 11 mil here and we're kind of
buying some items right now uh which
we'll explain a little bit for next
episode but we're getting some pages and
maybe we can guess what I'm going to do
with those but either way another 5 mil
here all right guys hope you enjoyed the
episode and if you did feel free to
leave the video a like and I will see
you guys in the next episode
a